mais toujours souriant et gentil
il porte bien son nom c'est juste
oh
formidable n'y a pas d'homme insiste
musée de la cohésion en ville à la rue
piétonne de la famille avec nos vieux
frères cf domaine il sait qu'ils jouent
de la guitare était à saint paul il
travaille semaines paires gardien et
souvent il y avait but had d'état buzz
ou ce mois c'est qui ça va remplacer a
dit quantité travail je rentre à
s'allier avec leur casque rose et iai
la résume pour apprendre la panna cotta
ont reconnu la seule fais pitié alors
mitali musique quoi c'est la seule phase
doreen vasseur l'acide aussi la seule
famille de nous comme lui le métier
notamment rothschild am ne fait pas la
dire madame goman que la zone mena dont
90 mais 50 ans tient ses comptes en dit
vous connais déjà écrit bin on m'a pas
pris bêtement comme ça ben ouvert la
pape rhône
c'était un restaurant d'écrire au chaud
à beaucoup de monde de la nuit des deux
d'édition jusqu'à 4,5 et matin comme si
je la connais exane est parce que
nouvelle génération peut déplacer mais
justement c'est qu'obama touche à la
santé qui joue la bonne heure les guérit
les cuivres que beaucoup n'avaient
aucune pied konin a beaucoup mais sont
politiques ou des jeux centaines on se
souvient que dos mais je vais la
cohésion
ça faisait de l'animation pour les gens
quoi mais la nouvelle génération ne
connais pas donc ça passe comme une
pièce ou quoi et pourtant il est bien
connu
oui mais comment s'est lancé moins mal
commencé mais la partie à batterie ça
maintenant résister mauvais ménage
contenir aucun cas heureusement forme
s'immoler en retard ligne en fait t'as
pas tout faire tout seul bambaataa déjà
de la courbe en voisin il doit pas trop
bien jusqu'à au matin parfois la folie
si bien nommée konan alpes au tribunal
quand on est à 80 il masque lui alors je
mets ainsi que je garde a manqué ni gay
marché n'a pas pris malades qui s'est
placé bas date
je suis pas date à ben oui depuis
longtemps parce que il est marié avec la
chaire ville de paris la fille du
disparu au sco
ben oui je sais la cjr nous sommes des
voisins il travaillait comme chauffeur
chez mon beau père fait partie du
paysage des gens comme ça
sont nécessaires c'est le musicien
populaire comme on en trouvait à
l'époque on en a connu un jeu maladie
c'est parce que avant la commission
d'amm à ses forêts et si raymond bol jeu
ven sam
il te rappelle sa bavette
la peau dont c'était absolument qu'ils
qui tient si elle est mauvaise idée de
la tête
non la crise à des jeunes comme la pire
la boum boum boum boum jeu certaines ont
calculé le temps de faire la charité
alors nom m'amuse et je suis pour faire
plaisir dès les personnes et les
personnels ce suisse qui veut mettre au
crédit m ne me demande pas multi pas à
mettre notre culture comme à nos amis
c'était un petit mener pour quoi pour
être ma retraite où est ma retraite
parce qu'ils me viendrait même à la 83e
600 personnes
mon jeu de mots importants mais a dû
présenter ses manières
bah c'est le seul qui reste je pense à
faire ça la réunion donc
ça sert à quoi ça sert à quoi qui ce qui
fait la musique à mettre l'ambiance dans
la ville de 5000 je pense pas mais moi
quand le bonduois dia - devenir mc bas
mais michel pas un bain dans la rift
valley s'est pas fait mais regrette pas
parce que mon appétit
il remercia ou bien un procès
et